you compare wack people to a monkey not
bunny I know today and everything is
racist this is front page at BuzzFeed
okay so let me give you how they
presented us they presented it as though
people were furious over video that
appears to show the chainsmokers a band
I believe joking about Chinese people
eating dogs now first this came from
BuzzFeed they say outraged you can see
some of the tweets but how much outrage
wasn't like it was a trend you know I
mean if it's a top trend you have to
address it because it's part of the
zeitgeist here these just BuzzFeed says
outraged and you kind of take their word
for it but yeah all the time I think
it's a good jumping-off point because if
you look at some of the tweets that they
include how dare you make fun of China
in China this is really insensitive
here's the thing after a very and I mean
very brief google search it was revealed
to me that they do eat dogs in China oh
like a lot so much so that they even
have a dog meat festival so this is
important to note where people are are
saying this is offensive how dare you
when they're saying how dare you what
they mean is reality this is what they
do well we find this idea heinous
obviously eating one's pet they
celebrate it with fireworks and a
festival in China I think we actually
have exclusive footage from the most
recent dog meat festival so much worse
than in writing that maybe in the line
no no no no no look behind you so this
is one thing that has really bothered me
for a while because I remember getting
this speech when I was in college it was
part of our humanities of course and you
can you know comment below as to if you
think it's outrageous to point out that
Chinese people eat dogs or what not gay
Jarrod just did if you think that that's
you know past the line but I remember we
had this exercise in philosophy those
humanities I don't have those philosophy
101 some kind of humanities course where
they're saying well what makes it okay
for you to judge you know someone eating
dogs and what makes you you're looking
at it through your culture we eat pigs
and other cultures they're seen as
domesticated animals and and the message
was it's never fair to judge another
culture through your cultural lens
they've been teaching this for a long
time but then they get offended when you
say the thing that they said
don't judge them on you wouldn't you
point out that they do because they're
assuming that it's bad they're assuming
that it's offensive by the way you know
who's not offended when you say hey
Chinese people eat dog all the people of
China
don't judge a culture because they're
different philosophy followed by mediate
hypocrisy and let me give you some
examples let's go back to Asians because
we've already crossed that so we've
covered these in the site there have
been plenty of articles complaining
about the stereotypical link of Asians
with martial arts so kind of like the
same thing right now with it's it's a
stereotypical link that Asians eat dogs
the Chinese people eat dogs
but then progressives came out and
accused white people of cultural
appropriation for doing martial arts so
it's it's a moving target where listen
reality is offensive and then once you
actually start taking part in this
reality that we've wanted you to deny
now we're going to accuse you of being
racist which let's go to another example
Kate listen let's just let's just be
frank here when you think of black
people okay what's one of the negatives
what do a lot of the instrument
watermelon is one I mean stop it come on
kool-aid right take you fried chicken oh
you just were trying to go down the list
because Jared's committing cultural
appropriation I'm gonna say why did you
get a grilled meal verse true it is true
there's no cholesterol I think program
is fun anyways you know they've been
saying one of the most classically sort
of offensive right black people and
fried chicken it's offensive it goes
back even a full metal jacket right
you're not supposed to talk about this
NPR's written articles about it people
have marched in the street comedians
have been protested but now if white
people just happen to eat fried chicken
its cultural appropriation here's from
the article fried chicken collard greens
baked macaroni cheese fried fish these
food chains are making millions by
producing typical food from the
african-american culture for the masses
prints these mostly white people well
why people do tend to make up the masses
we have to soul food damn that was a
universal thing you know it at what
point we like it yeah it's tasty people
used to be recognized for their culture
we had cultural week in the most liberal
school I could possibly imagine on the
south shore
of montreal centennial regional high
school and 90% of it was just people
bringing in food yeah so if I just if I
happen to like scotch is am I now
culturally appropriating this guy just
be like they're known for that it's okay
well I guess but at the Chinese probably
feel left out
they're trying to make their own scotch
I'm gonna move on down the next cultural
fare table there's a Polish man with
some pierogies I think I'll roll the
dice with those master Chang so let's go
to even more recently Arabic culture of
course we talked about this this week
Aladdin they've complained that there's
a white person was cast in Aladdin but
if you go back they also complained that
a lad in itself was negatively
stereotyping Arabic culture even though
by the way he was sent to a Chinese
tailor in the original one no dogs right
yeah he's kind of realized they do not
want you to win that's the game they've
actually played their game it's moving
gold posts and the goalposts it can also
include just reality but these are the
same people who want us to tear down
monuments for fear of offending people
as Confederacy monuments or George
Washington there been proposals for that
so of course they're gonna say that it's
racist to point to anyone elses a
cultural history like China's one-child
policy leading to the countless murders
of young girls including by the way
master awnings no listen that's kind of
messed up on that one oh my god please
subscribe please stay subscribed what's
these are the same people who Clinton
pointing out real cultural differences
right is racist so pointing out that
listen they eat dogs in China that's
racist pointing out that there are
certain foods that are more popular in
black culture and where does it by the
way it doesn't just come out of nowhere
and this is the problem because there
are actual racists out there okay and
it's important to limit but saying hey
culturally black people tend to eat this
the these kinds of food because it comes
from being back in the deep south it
does come sometimes from roots and
slavery and the kinds of foods that they
would eat back then and they've carried
it down as a matter of fact if you look
at white Southerners they have more in
common with black Americans and probably
anyone else in the country there's a lot
of the same lingo
there's a lot of the same slang there's
a lot of the same kind of food and
beverages that they drink the beauty is
listen when you just acknowledge
cultural differences when you accept
reality that there are cultural
differences sometimes they can actually
serve to bring people together don't
figure I actually enjoy fried chicken
and I'm appreciating their culture not
appropriating it okay we didn't say it
was their culture that you just did say
that's the rate this is no racist I'm
talking about what's gonna happen when I
spoke up again they get so mad when you
acknowledge reality and then they then
they create racism and when I say
they're yes I do mean the regressive
left eye no peered up because it just
shut up okay there's no one on the right
who is going out accusing you of being
racist or trying to get you fired
because you say they eat dogs and China
they have a dog eating festival there's
no one you can find in the moderate to
right wing who will start a March over
that okay it's not calling to happen but
then the left finds racism where it
doesn't exist like this infamous story
we covered it on the website laterthe
credit I come where the banana peel in
the tree it I think it's art washington
times it was confused for a hate crime
like five read-throughs that article
just i genuinely just to make the
connection until i realized oh liberals
assume that everyone else is comparing
black people's apes therefore a banana
peel is something that would be
appealing to an ape so they're racist it
didn't even occur to me i would never
walk across a banana peel it i'd walk
across and i'd probably think of the
three stooges i would probably think of
an old vaudevillian actor Shammi mario
has company over there with his go-kart
it is remarkable to me they find racism
where it doesn't exist and try to
copy-paste it to other people who
genuinely when we read the news articles
it never occurred to us even when you
told us that it should and then we say
well okay so you think everyone else is
making that comparison so maybe you're
the racist way
you could be a wacky fool draw a monkey
in a banana flame breakfast at tiffany's
and Mickey Rooney that is that man's
legacy and I will honor it
hey did you like this video of course
you did
let's there's something wrong with you
in which case you can comment below
what's your problem with this video we
want to hear from you and we promise you
100% I give you my word as my bond will
answer every single negative comment for
those who are normal you can leave a
thumbs up and subscribe